we know that the trans agenda is
anti-truth anti-reality anti-science but
that alone is is not what makes it so
harmful i mean flat earthers are also
anti-reality and yet we don't spend a
lot of time worrying that our kids will
get sucked into that cult what makes the
trans agenda so dangerous and
destructive is that the truths it
militates against are the most basic
truths of all it seeks to warp a
person's understanding of
themselves of their own identity it's
one thing to have wild misconceptions
about the shape of the earth
it's another to have wild misconceptions
about yourself your body your identity
or your place in the world
but the trans cult does something else
too which many other cults before it
have done though none with anywhere near
this level of success
it attacks and destabilizes the family
one of the many truths that it opposes
is the truth of the nuclear family it
hates
the family because that institution the
family attests so powerfully to the true
nature of the human person and of the
two sexes
it also hates the family because
children raised in stable families
protected and guided by parents in a
loving and sturdy marriage
are much more difficult to reach
and indoctrinate
they're not impervious they're not
impervious to brainwashing but they are
significantly shielded against it
a family provides a child with an anchor
he is secured he's sheltered protected
the groomers then have to take away this
anchor blow up the family
leaving kids unmoored and unprotected
vulnerable
like like a baby deer wandering through
the forest easy prey for the wolves
this is why the groomer spent so much
time and so much effort trying
desperately to to place this wedge in
between the child and the parent this is
why we hear about so many schools that
have policies of intentionally hiding a
student's lgbt self-identification from
parents and even even after all the
backlash and outrage over these sorts of
policies
still many teachers continue to engage
in this kind of predatory behavior and
brag about it openly here's just the the
latest example from this week
if you as a teacher have a student come
to you and tell you that they are
gay part of the lgbtq community whether
they are
looking into transitioning anything like
that but they don't want their parents
to know yet
the question on the news was
as a teacher is it your responsibility
or as a school is it your responsibility
to inform the parents of what their
child is going through
on the news they all said yes it is the
schools the teachers the counselors
due diligence to let these parents know
what the kids are going through
as a teacher i disagree um i did have a
student come and tell me this last year
that she was gay
she did not want her mom to know and i
respected her wishes
now that teacher like so many others
wants to have
intimate knowledge of a child that the
child's parents
do not have
this is a classic cult tactic it's right
from the cult handbook the recruiter of
the cult seeks to form a bond with the
recruit that supersedes any bond they
have with anybody else including and
especially family members
take that crowbar and pry the child away
from the parent that's the idea and
increasingly
the prying is taking more aggressive and
invasive forms often involving the
courts acting as the the crowbar
in my film what is a woman we heard the
story of course of a father in canada
who was sent to jail
and lost custody of his daughter because
he wouldn't affirm her as a boy for
simply insisting that his daughter is
his daughter
that she is his daughter and not his son
that the girl he helped conceive and
raise still exists
he lost everything
this sort of thing happens frequently in
canada and will become even more
frequent with the recent passage of an
anti-conversion therapy law so-called
which declares it an illegal form of
conversion therapy for anyone including
parents to refuse to use biologically
incorrect pronouns for a child
if you do that if you call a girl
she
and she wants to be called he then you
are now engaging in conversion therapy
it's against the law
your criminal will put you in jail i'll
take your kids away
but it's also starting to happen in the
u.s
now there have already been well-known
cases like the jeff younger case that
you've
probably heard about um even before that
there were cases like one in ohio for
example where two parents in this case
their two parents still married
lost custody of their daughter because
they refused to allow her to medically
transition into a boy
the judge legally kidnapped the girl
and and gave custody to the grandparents
that she judge sylvia hendon trusted
would facilitate the child drugging and
mutilation now that happened back in
2018
and it's only going to become more
common now as as time continues
which means we're going to see more and
more stories like that of jeanette
cooper
now jeanette cooper is a 44 year old
woman
who's a tragic tale was highlighted this
week by journalist kelsey bolar of the
independent women's forum on the iwb on
the iwf website
she tells tells the story of how cooper
who's the mother to a 12 year old girl
also by the way a lifelong progressive
democrat
by no means is this like a conservative
with an axe to grind ideologically
it's a progressive democrat woman and
mother
lost custody of her daughter because
unlike her ex-husband
she wouldn't affirm her daughter's
deluded idea that she was really a boy
reading now from the article says
jeanette cooper never imagined she'd
lose custody of her child the 44 year
old lifelong educator always considered
herself a loving and responsible mother
to her daughter sophia
but when at age 12 sophia suddenly
claimed to be transgender jeannette was
skeptical sophia had never exhibited
signs of gender dysphoria in fact sophia
exhibited many more traditionally
feminine behaviors and preferences than
jeannette ever had
to jeannette it didn't make sense but
sophia insisted not only that she was
trans but that she was unsafe around
jeanette
what followed was an almost kafka-esque
series of court proceedings and therapy
sessions in which jeanette's ex-husband
lawyers therapist and other individuals
in institutions supposedly concerned
with sophia's best interests worked to
erode jeannette's most basic parenting
rights
nearly three years later jeannette can't
even visit with the daughter she loves
she lives less than 10 minutes away but
can only communicate with sofia by u.s
mail
all because she insists that sophia is a
girl
now from here we're told
the whole story about how jeannette and
her husband divorced in 2015 now at
first jeannette was as very often
happens was awarded almost full custody
of her daughter she had her daughter six
days a week
but then one day at the age of 12 her
daughter goes for a visit
to her father's
who by the way had recently remarried
and it was now married to a
psychotherapist
and she goes for the visit it never
returns
the girl announced out of nowhere that
she was trans and couldn't live with her
mother anymore because her mother's
disagreement with trans ideology made
her feel unsafe
now jeannette suspects and with good
reason i'm guessing
that the girl's psychotherapist's
stepmom has a lot to do with her
daughter's discovery of her male
identity uh there's probably something
to that theory but but also
i'm sure she picked it up from school
she picked it up from social media
we've heard this story over and over and
over again
so many parents with this exact story
most of the time they're adolescent
girls but not always
girls perfectly fine
no signs of gender dysphoria at all no
indication ever at any point in her life
that she was confused about her gender
and then one day out of nowhere just
like that
she says oh i'm trans trans
now in this case the court ordered an
investigation of jeannette
to find out um if her daughter was
actually unsafe around her because
that's what the daughter said so they
they ordered an investigation
took seven months
investigating this mother
and found no abuse no neglect
but they did decide that jeannette needs
to quote further her understanding of
and support of the minor child as
relates to the minor child's gender
dysphoria
translation she's not on board with the
trans agenda and so she can't see her
daughter anymore
and she hasn't
she hasn't had any physical contact with
her child for the past three years
now eventually
and this is where it gets even more
sinister if that's possible
eventually she was forced to negotiate a
deal
right and here here is the deal that she
was given by the court
in exchange for giving up any legal
right to see her daughter again
she was assured in writing
that her daughter would not undergo a
medical transition without her
permission or a court order okay so this
is the deal with the devil that parents
are now forced to make give up your
rights to your daughter or we will
mutilate her we will cut her to pieces
if you don't give up your rights to her
imagine being a parent and having to
face that decision
and so she says well i guess i have no
choice i'm never going to see my
daughter again
but at least she won't be mutilated
but the thing is you know part of the
deal here is that even if you agree
uh with a court order we can still
mutilate her
and we know how easy it is to get the
court order
jeannette points out correctly that
murderers in prison now have more
communication and contact with their
children than she does
that kind of makes sense in a certain
way because as far as the system is
concerned she's worse than a murderer
i mean she's a transphobe
that's the cardinal sin
there's an interview on youtube that
janette did with the independent women's
forum worth watching she explains why
she rejects the idea that she should
simply have you know relented and
allowed her daughter to take the lead
and do whatever she wants here's what
she says about that
and what i have been told is to follow
her lead
to follow her in this journey
i am not willing to do that i don't
think that is good parenting it's my
responsibility not to hook my boat to
hers
it is my responsibility to be a
lighthouse
to be something stable that she can see
some guide that she has that will always
be there that is consistent i still do
that today even though i have no custody
of her i have no medical decision making
no educational decision making and no
way to communicate with her other than
by mail
you know one thing you can see just
watching that video is i mentioned this
is a progressive democrat
feminist the mother is and you could
tell just by looking at her this is you
know she partially shaved head in the
whole nine yards uh this is this and she
talks about in the article too in the
interview how she doesn't even she
doesn't believe in traditional gender
roles so so
but but even then
not not good enough as far as the as far
as the far left radicals on the court
are concerned you know in in family
court as far as they're concerned still
not good enough
you you're progressive democrat
um everything else feminist
not good enough
your kid's still not safe
because there's this one item on the
progressive agenda that you do not go
along with
the imagery that she you know mentions
there of a lighthouse is quite powerful
and it's correct
if your child is lost in the fog of
confusion not sure which way is up not
able to discern east from west not sure
who they are
your job as a parent is to be a light
and a voice
of of calm and clarity
it's not to abandon your child to the
mist and say hey just wander around in
whatever direction you want you'll
figure it out yeah whatever just go yeah
go that way it's fine
but that's the strategy the court
demands
turn the light off
leave your child to the dark
or else we'll take her from you they say
now um
sort of at the at the the end of this
story here at least up until this point
most recent development
is jeanette's daughter doesn't even
identify as trans anymore
okay so when so when she originally came
out as quote trans and her mother said i
don't buy it
she was right
she doesn't identify as trans anymore
she identifies as non-binary and uses z
zerzer's pronouns
which means that this is included too by
the way we take your kids away
affirm your daughter as a zir
whatever the hell that is
or will take her from you
of course if you're in this position as
a parent and you say it and you ask the
court what even is azure like what does
that mean what do you add what are you
telling me i have to do
i can't explain it it's total nonsense
but what does it mean for the girl it
means that she's grappling around
helplessly she's totally lost and
confused she has no idea who she is
[Music]
but that's exactly what the groomers
want
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really is that's what
it is we're forming a cult then all you
got to do is click the subscribe button
and ring the bell below uh this video to
stay up to date with all my content and
if you want even more you can watch or
listen to my show at thedailywire.com
spotify or apple podcast looking forward
to welcoming you to the sweet baby gang